order
really
you clicked on this you know this is
Pluto - right
this is like one of the biggest
box-office bombs that ever existed I
much rather you watch a video in the
side scroller but put me to work for
this it's really ok I won't mind there's
lots more interesting videos look there
cinemas not reviewing how make occur
cameras they've making Mike Myers on
naked Christmas the twist is it's really
naked Kwanzaa would you much rather
watch that okay you're so insistent
let's go ahead and take a look at this
stinker day Oh baby head no no guys
they're watching the video they are but
they know it's Pluto Nash right that's
what I told them but they're still
watching we were gonna get drunker than
someone who watched Pluto Nash I know
but they want to see review of it so get
in your costumes thanks a lot dick holes
you can take your love of Eddie Murphy
and shove it up your ass
funny most Eddie Murphy movies don't
stop a drinking thunder they usually
start them
you notice the most expensive yet lazy
comedic bomb since Netanyahu spoke at
the UN Pluto Nash lacks any sort of
charm originality and yes even comedy in
what's supposed to be a charming
original and comedic Ville this movies
put on God knows how many worst films
ever listened in many respects I can
understand but in others it just doesn't
seem worth the effort hell they didn't
even put the effort in to convert it to
blu-ray they care so little it's so not
worth the effort I am literally phoning
in this review right now yeah
I'm not even here I'm wasting my time on
this shit I'm actually preparing for the
next review I swear this isn't a clue so
let's start off with the joke I know
you're all waiting for me to make
trust me this is trying harder than
anything in the film this is Pluto Nash
after reading a slew of actors thinking
to yourself oh yeah they were a thing
because they were in that thing we see
Jay Mohr doing horrible as a musician in
a bar how do we know he's doing bad
because he has an accordion of course
apparently we still like this nerdy
cliche Oh what was the taped up glasses
bowtie and holding books musician not
available he also seems to be the owner
of the bar who serves his friend just
because the script says he's his friend
Eddie Murphy
there you go Pluto answer to me be a
problem will you keep a name Pluto Nash
what's the first thing that comes into
your head
after that b-movie space adventures
goofy characters shooting laser guns but
the strange thing about this film is
they're surprisingly not much of that
don't get me wrong there are some space
suits and robots and such but the story
is mostly a straightforward mystery hell
it surprisingly kind of takes its
storyline very seriously just look at
all these serious conversations they
have Orochi had the Bucks he had the
background why is he so set in buying
your clothes he's gotten to the City
Council cuz they're about to approve
gamblin in his town the clone doctor
named Runa padang c'n Runa was dealing
with some pretty heavy characters but
she didn't tell me who so if you're
gonna be lame enough to actually tell us
we're supposed to take this story
seriously how seriously can we take it
if we're constantly hearing hello
Oh Pluto Pluto not much greatest irony
is Murphy talks to more about changing
his act as well as his name because it
sounds so ridiculous but this could just
as easily be him talking about the
movie's name and act if the movie sat
down next to Murphy saying its name was
Pluto Nash he'd be like that's not even
a thing did you make that up it's
horrible it's horrible you know what you
need to do a Tony Francis do you like
that change the name or something more
sensible like Jupiter Jones
so Pluto is busy doing unexplained
occupation as Adrian's brother comes in
proving once and for all that less
should equal more who is my best friend
oh please kill my career my biggest
claim to fame is working with mafia you
mean I saw the comedy that bombed almost
as big as this one
he says it's back to football it's like
more owes the money but Pluto I hope I
never get used to saying that steps in
and says he'll cover his debt with his
mysterious income as well as by the bar
my gift to you we got a mere seven years
later in almost the exact same
establishing shot yeah they're showing
the city from so many angles like up off
shot and slightly left of the above shot
as the bar is really taken off and
turned into a dance club
hey everybody do the not trying okay
place your bets now 18 and under club
for Mormon ray well third option ironic
space mutiny party so Pluto God what
cruel parents comes across a young
waitress looking for work to pay her way
home played by Rosario Dawson's my moon
card expired and I was told you were the
one person in town who might actually
overlook that rosy you said yes to a
movie that had the word moon card in it
what's next clips to only there's a love
scene with the donkey actually to
Dawson's credit even when she's in bad
movies she always looks like the only
one who's ever friggin try everyone else
acts like they can do this role on their
sleep in fact I think Murphy is half the
time you know what time it is will be
calling me this time a night what's
wrong with you know sorry sometimes I
sleepwalk with my eyes open
was I talking to my sleep too but two
representatives of Rex crater okay did
they steal these names from the Cowboys
of MU Mesa want to buy is club for ten
million dollars or as they call it
ten million hilary's okay this is a
tough one because as of the date this
review is coming out I don't know if
this is incredibly clever or incredibly
dated so but first time ever I am giving
you a multiple choice joke just come
back after November 8th and choose from
one of these options
hey well they can obviously throw that
prop in the fire it wouldn't be the
first time she felt the burn be bland
she bought the rest of Hollywood to get
the presidency are we really surprised
by this or see if I can't get the
Muslims out in the rightful title did
tonight
look it to be the burn
Pluto turns them down and as his
bodyguard Android played by Canada's
most dangerous criminal Randy Quaid to
escort them out model 63 talk about
ancient your sister didn't seem to mind
screw you robot boy that metal played in
Eddie's head have bigger consequences
than I thought
after Dawson slips into her most
comfortable hatching out of a vagina
made out of a crepe-paper outfit come on
ladies you all know you have won both
her and Pluto drinks some moonshine spit
on that chick later why would and he
looks over his finances I'm plastic
paper because you know plastic paper
equals the future but his club is blown
up by roots craters goons this looks
like a job for his finest water pistol
Bruno moon I think that's one of them
I'll intercept the call Nash is alive he
took off after Jimmy was headed for the
back thanks for the Cadbury egg cam who
exactly did layout work on that so mr.
director what do we do for the scene
we're we're on it gosh I'm so glad they
didn't replace you with that other
director walk they escaped the gangsters
and hide out as Pluto tries to ask some
questions about what's going on I got to
get to Rex crater forget it nobody gets
to him who the hell is this guy he lives
in a penthouse above the lunar Grand
Hotel never comes out rolling you was a
cop for 20 years
you gotta have some kind of idea who he
is some people think he's our clone by
god it's amazing how not interested they
are this movie should have a menu of not
caring this hmm yes I might want the
disinterested acting with a hint of
tiredness though I've heard great things
about the half as acting with a splash
of who gives a shit
Oh Who am I kidding I'm saving myself
for the desert of disappointing
conclusion I hear that the most popular
of Eddie Murphy movies nowadays
meanwhile Dawson stays behind to look
after Randy Quaid's rape face until some
answers can be discovered where did the
boss go I don't know
out he said to wait from here out okay
what's he modeled after the thermians
from Galaxy Quest where were we going
boss you will find my voice is grating
as a blender on your dad's he gets a tip
that makeover lab might have some clues
to draw him closer what exactly did you
have in mind we could start with some
ass free sculpting for her to get a
little more uh bubbling yeah thanks for
your help on this case now let me reward
you by insulting your goddess like
Bonnie how the hell does this Joe keep
it makes sense yeah that was probably
impressive at the time but now is most
likely an app on your phone
I'll future thinking it you need to
rethink the ass enhancement of the work
and a HelpOut talking titties galore
let's happen titties really flowing yeah
okay movie did you just forget that
Rosario Dawson's body is flawless this
isn't a 2 ohm and Obi men scene this is
a what the Christ is wrong with you you
selfish asshole see it's like getting a
tank for Christmas and being like doh I
wanted one more wheel why are you such
an ungrateful jackass Hey look Pam Grier
is his mother there's literally no
reason for this character except to say
that so moving on they figure out they
need to go to the far side of the Moon
to figure out who's behind this which
means leaving their incredibly
phenomenally bland City yeah maybe 10 or
15 years prior to this these designs
will look cool but something really
weird happened when the movie Blade
Runner came out for whatever reason
everybody said yeah let's make every
single future city in any sci-fi film
look like that and that's what we got
for years
Super Mario Brothers Judge Dredd a.i
Total Recall Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy Cloud Atlas demolition man they
all look like the exact same town I mean
we're the movie guys watching from afar
saying now hear this every future city
in film art
exactly the same oh come on you're
barely trying with that performance yeah
because no one gives a shit if we try on
this one that's not true these poor
people are sitting through this review
hoping nay praying that something
beneficial can finally be connected to
Pluto Nash I don't even get it we're
movie gods
yeah did you put any time into this joke
probably not it's Pluto Nash how come
you get away with half-assing it but we
can't you don't understand
I've sat through this buffet of blandest
I've tasted the nectar of indifference
I've suffered enough but we can't be
making things any better for as it is
told every time the name Pluto Nash is
uttered an accountant drags himself out
into the streets and shoots himself that
is complete nonsense and apparently we
live next door to accountants but
nevertheless you do this with passion
fine now hear this every future city in
film should look exactly the same yeah
so what passion we are just with the
passion of Kevin Costner okay good
enough oh come on even the music's not
trying curse you Pluto Nash
heroes end up stealing a car so they
won't be tracked because nobody would be
looking for a stolen car and it
apparently has the AI of John Cleese not
being funny I'll give you to the count
of three before I let the authorities 1
- disconnected your alarm relay circuit
moving jimmy-boy good god I'm being
stolen hey everything else from this
movie is stolen why not you two again
not sure if clever or wishful thinking
thus they partake in a romantic scene
that'll have you saying boy they
memorize those lines it's nice it's nice
look at this oh come on it's a beautiful
bed green screen out tonight don't touch
those Zephyr guests my God he's gonna
get her drunken of his way with that
what do you even say to a line like that
boo Dawson imitates the audience by
falling asleep but wakes up when they
finally seem to be doing some actual
space stuff getting out spacesuits and
jumping outside with little gravity well
enough of that shit come on this is
Pluto - you were expecting more with a
title like that
no no we know how invested you are in
the mystery so we're mostly gonna focus
on that again
computers got no information on our
mystery man sundar said wzw no mzm
initiate search this movie is like Mars
Needs Moms you don't think it's gonna be
good but you'd think you get something
that represents the title Mars Needs Maz
instead you get something dark angry and
upsettingly boring and here's the mask
out of everything dark angry and
upsettingly boring Alec Baldwin as he
plays a character who they think is
behind everything what are you waiting
for a dance
oh oh I forgot the stairs was that yeah
yeah I don't even think he's acting I
think this is just a camera crew
witnessing a usual Baldwin outing oh and
for the record he never comes back
yeah I'm not kidding that's his only
appearance in the film I don't know if
they're trying to throw us for a loop
making us think he's the villain but if
you have a star for only a few seconds
and then say hey maybe it's him is
probably not him it's like thinking the
surprise villain and a spider-man movie
is Bruce Campbell it's probably not
gonna happen as awesome as that would be
a great worked on three designs that
ideas so cool man that won't save the
third movie Hey look a cryogenically
frozen dog popped a little bitch in the
particle way for two minutes on to frog
should be heard all around the room well
no one nowhere will just throw that in
the dumpster with all the other things
that seem to have no purpose okay now
that joke I know I can say is David
unless they're new catchphrases you got
hosed
but finally we get a little bit of moon
action as the gangsters find them and
they have a little battle outside and
anybody lose a directionless joke Hey
look the main lost your dress I don't
get it either so
oh come on their heads didn't even touch
and even if they did the gravity slowing
everything down would be the equivalent
of a light push careful he might blink
really hard at you next so these at
their ray guns are getting their space
well at least this sounds like something
that would be in a movie called
Adventures of Pluto Nash the only
downside is it's about as exciting as a
Phantom Menace potteries great strategy
maybe you can throw in the word now to
emphasize the detail of your plan they
scape and come across a man named Felix
who says he can take them to the city
where Rex crater is but not before
recharging their body guard you know I
usually jump at the opportunity to make
a dick joke but in this case I feel like
I'd be robbing a future dick joke that
was worth much more effort so I'm just
gonna steal one from my labyrinth review
I know it doesn't really connect but mmm
so they go from one every other future
city to another every other future city
where they tried to sneak around in
disguise because clearly I would never
pick them out of a crowd but oh the slot
machine is a bit of a slot machine as it
has the hots for Randy Quaid hey
good-looking
how about slipping up to your room and
playing with me for a while come on big
boy right here in the lobby Oh baby you
sick bastard
security would program a machine to do
that I'll be all sex in the city slots
now we have a machine pressing charges
on a machine it's not like a toaster
suing a microwave does anybody really
gain anything but hey remember the
advice Jay Mohr got from Eddie Murphy
well it turns out that transformed him
into a superstar singer selling out
theaters every night before hell did
that happen in a one-minute conversation
you changed this into this that's like
saying you know maybe if you take off
those glasses and change your hair you
look more attractive
whoa I'm amazing I guess but more
gangsters are hunting them down so Pluto
goes in for a kid so they won't be
noticed mmm tastes like fading career I
think they worked yeah cuz if there's
anybody who would be aroused by that
it's rosario Dawson not Eddie Murphy but
then again she does have that non
impressive ass movie what you want this
is speaking of which she tries to break
Wayde out of his holding cell for
damaging the slot machine well you would
be a real peach if you could get me that
though well I do have a penis so do I
not your ass could use a little work
though damn it
as the last time we put stereotypical
dumb guard bot on duty what they get
caught immediately after so for the O's
keeping track at home that's an hour and
17 minutes as they managed to capture
Pluto as well and show him the man
behind everything
so you got it all figured out huh
they don't do that lord knows this movie
deserves a sequel but they end up doing
this weird thing where they have a look
left and right for some reason
why the hell did he do that
yeah I'm not concerned about what a weak
pointless out of nowhere twist this is
I'm more concerned about why the hell he
just did that weird head turn was he
showing off his earrings the doctor
checking his balls and he just forgot to
cough or maybe he was distracted by the
check they were constantly waving in
front of him so he wouldn't run off set
yeah with that excitement it must have
been the check so I know what you're
thinking what uh hell was the plot of
this again because when you really look
back and remember it it's spectacular
uninteresting Pluto was cloned years ago
by a businessman who wanted to use him
as a puppet but buddy love didn't want
to be a puppet so he killed the guy who
clothed him allowing him to take control
what does this mean for Pluto Nash well
his clone just wants to buy his bar
that's it yeah who cares why the hell is
this the least bit interesting nothing
of any real value is on the line even at
the beginning he just sort of bought the
bar to save a friend he didn't really
have that much interest in it so nobody
really gives a crap about what happens
in this movie if you told me the goal of
the film was to save a toy anus that
would have me more sucked in than
anything that they just showed unless
eels use as a joke to make fun of
Dawson's ass I'm sorry I'm not letting
that go that is perfection
so Murphy has the most symbolic battle
representing his career as he fights
himself over who's going to kill him
faster
thank God they both happen to be wearing
the same suit lucky lucky actually to
the film's credit there is one
brilliantly funny see
it was only a second but my god that
simple staging is friggin hilarious I'll
definitely give that a point
unfortunately next to all the negative
points it does really downtown this is
for daddy day game this is the Norbit
this is for me day and this is for
defendant Bill Cosby when everybody knew
he was guilty yeah look it up I did crap
saloon no sorry I mean a man has fallen
to death on the table sorry I always
confuse that for crash so seemingly
nothing really changes as Pluto goes
back to his club and everything seems to
go back to normal the only difference is
he lets Dawson become a singer which he
probably would have done anyway and
let's Quaid run the place which he also
probably would have done anyway well no
robots ever been in management you want
the job don't you oh gosh just remember
we can't serve joy it's around here my
hypocrisy goes only so far we end on
Murphy doing his creeper face and we're
cheerfully reminded of the ultimate
lesson if a clone of you wants to turn
your bar into a casino don't let it
don't get drunk yes where are you
keeping that you don't want to know okay
this movie is not only a bad comedy but
half the time I don't even know if it's
trying to be a comic it is so
unimaginative
and so boring that I don't even know if
it's worth getting angry over
it's just forgettable pretty much
nothing to take away from it I guess
it's a failure that's a very interesting
kind of failure one that had so much
money thrown at it and yet it still
turns out so bland but aside from that
this is one I doubt anyone's gonna be
looking to come back to anytime soon
and thank God because I don't know how
much more of this I could have phoned in
I still swear this isn't a clue what
were you reveal if you don't want no may
come out let's talk about something that
mattered
you
I'm talking titties galore Atlas him
titties really flowing
heydo walker here before i do the
charity shout out i just wanted to say
we give a pretty big clue as to what the
next NC review is going to be and if you
want to know my honest thoughts on it
before that comes out just not in
character just my honest thoughts you
can check out awesome comics a brand new
show that just came out and the first
episode we talk about Batman vs Superman
so you can definitely go check that out
here a whole bunch of my opinions just
out of character pretty much what I
thought and now we're on to the charity
shout-out and this week we are doing the
American Society for the Prevention of
Cruelty to Animals this is the first
humane society to be established in
North America and is one of the largest
in the world it was founded on the
belief that animals are entitled to kind
and respectful treatment and must be
protected under the law they maintain a
strong presence with programs that
extend their anti cruelty mission across
the country and are recognized as a
national animal welfare organization
posting more than 2 million supporters
across the country if you look at their
site in their YouTube channel you can
see all the pets they helped get back to
a normal love filled life that they
deserve come on look at these guys you
can't say no to them reach out and lend
a paw to help these beauties get the
best treatment they deserve stop by
their site and see all the great work
that they do
you